though our lives are finite life
is infinite and we are part of
continuums
we we were born of parents
and whether we have our own children we
definitely will have lots of friends and
relationships
throughout our lives and we will have
impact and so we have a choice
remember there's three things we always
consider you don't get to choose the
rules of the game
right life is an infinite game with us
or without us
born die life continues life doesn't
care
right it continues with us without us um
we can choose if we want to play in the
game in this case you don't get a choice
you're born you're in unlike business
you can choose if you want to start a
business or not
but the third thing is we get to choose
how we play the game
and so yes uh you can absolutely play uh
uh life the game of life with a finite
mindset and the way that looks is i'm
gonna be number one
i'm gonna make every decision as to what
what will pay me more which will get me
more power which will get me more
influence
i remember talking to a guy who was it
was a friend of uh
it was the husband of my a friend of my
sisters and he was in a dark place in
his
career he just lost his job and he
wanted my advice he wanted to help find
his why and i got on the phone with him
we started talking
and i tried to find i started asking him
questions about tell me
a time in your career where you loved
what you were doing
he could not think of one he could not
think of one
project one instance one job he's ever
had that he loved being a part of
and i asked him how he chose his jobs
and every single time he changed jobs
it was because of the salary that was
offered to him when he graduated college
he took the first job that offered him
the highest salary
he had competing offers the second job
he took the highest salary the third job
he took the highest salary
he only ever took jobs that paid him
more and now he was
unbelievably unhappy and had nothing to
look back
to had very few relationships had very
few
uh um loyal relationships that he could
call upon
because he was always selfishly directed
he had chosen to play with a finite
mindset
it's a choice it usually comes with a
lot of uh
health problems as well creates more
stress
and all the other health related things
that come with stress
or we can choose to play with an
infinite mindset and what that means is
we live our lives with the knowledge
that we will die
and we want to leave this world our
company our families our friends in
better shape
than when we found them i think about
that for a second
that when when our friends and family go
to our funeral
they will stand and cry and talk about
that they would not be the person they
are today
if it weren't for having you in their
lives and so many people think about
their legacies at the end of their lives
when they
face their own mortality that's the
problem only when they face their
mortality
do they start thinking about legacy and
giving and and giving to charity and
giving it all away
why not do that when you're 21 why not
do that when you're 18 why not live your
entire life
thinking about your legacy meaning what
impact will we have in the lives of
others
no one wants to be remembered for the
amount of money they made no one wants
on their tombstone
the last balance in their bank account
or the title on their business card
we want to be remembered for the impact
we had in the lives of others devoted
mother loving father
that's how you live an infinite life
even though our lives are finite
you